looks like the purp stole a computer a
watch and a hamon Iberico ham valued at
what six thousand dollars six thousand
dollars for a ham hormone is an amazing
cured ham from Spain they had at my
uncle's funeral I gorged myself at that
funeral I mean I was constipated for
three days wow that's a great story
Charles thank you
hey Boyle yep what about this fancy ham
stuff I'm on America yes the purp left
really expensive TV but then stole ham
doesn't make sense is there a place
nearby the crime scene that sells it
benefit shows might let's go you gotta
breathe the co first brief him after we
catch the guy
[Music]
my name is
I don't know anything oh okay you
recognize this guy Henry morgentham no
maybe actually look at the picture I
don't know him I don't know what
happened no more questions well why
don't I run a scenario past you Rocco
and you tell me what you think you do
know morgenthau he came in here tried to
sell you some hams you knew they were
worth a lot of money so you tried to
steal them from him when he wasn't home
only he was home so you shot him does
that sound familiar
uh maybe some role play will Jack your
memory it's a great idea okay yeah okay
victim
I'm not doing that
fine oh
owner of delicious and expensive hams
don't I know you from the grocery store
kill and scene
and my free day everyone day
ma'am if you could just get down or
ignore me and continue shopping we'll
get the door all right go
out
Japan
I'm getting mad it's a waste of manchego
how are you still here little house
[Music]
episode
hey Captain somebody found something hey
I like the time
if you can't beat him join them anyway I
think I got something good here turns
out the name Radco is made up but I was
digging through these files one of which
I literally found in a spider web it
turns out there were a bunch of
references to a Serbian Thug street
names the rat and the butcher he was
known to hang out at a storage unit near
Borum Park which has red soil hence the
muddy red footprint on morgenthau's
counter
that's fine work Detective
thank you very much sir Testament to
what can be achieved when you dress
appropriately
found it out
what are you trying to tell us is this
some kind of a clue
draw better we have no idea what this is
I think it's a cookie no it's a
Pizza it's a good
another case
subjectives
she's taking it somewhere this is good
this is good we're gonna crack this
diazia nope she just seen you take a
dump
Rob
come on in
he called the tip line but he's so
not crazy looking Rosa have Abdallah and
I taught you nothing about stereotyping
I'm beginning to feel like you're our
biggest project sweetie enough what did
he tell you well let's find out okay
together Rob do you want to share your
experience with the group gladly okay so
you know how there's a Subterranean race
of lizard people living beneath the city
who control our minds with their
pheromones
okay he's a wackadoodle Tina get your
whack a doodle out of here well Marshawn
Lynch will not leave your office he has
now pulled up one of those wedding
proposal viral videos on his phone and
is crying what did I do to deserve this
well I haven't fared any better she
keeps drawing her stupid Circle pictures
and then running off to the bathroom
yes sir we get it you have a bum Tom yes
you think you guys have it rough I've
been stuck here listening to Crazy Rob's
spew his insane garbage what happened to
your positive attitude Abdullah don't
even say the name right tweeted him and
got nothing meanwhile Rob tweets on some
crap about lizard people he's like oh
retweed ooh fave everything I just told
him I saw one of them slip back into his
lizard home under the streets that's
where they make their soup oh my God
he's onto something Captain don't try to
be nice by giving a crazy person a voice
plus we've already learned that human
rights are crap no he said that the
lizard people live under the streets he
means the sewers he saw someone go from
the van into the sewers look
it's a manhole cover
somebody stole my laptop which contained
the unpublished manuscript of book 13 of
the sky fire cycle
person left this note
we have your book pay us five hundred
thousand dollars in the next 24 hours or
we leak it online the first five
chapters are now up we've been
downloaded 85 000 times Well we should
probably go online and read those
chapters in case there's some clues in
there and also maybe we'll find out
condor's true parentage well that's
already been revealed no it hasn't
unless the prophecy of door God is
indeed true but that would mean it's the
exact same note guy I don't see why
anybody would want to steal your book
The Sky fire cycle makes the shadow
bringer cycle look like the beastwarm
chronicle these heroes are the Beast
worm Chronicles are one of the more
simplistic don't care yeah you know what
my books say something okay I was the
only one brave enough to tackle elf
molestation guys calm down you're both
victims now do you have any enemies in
common let me think about that parlov is
my enemy but he's also his own enemy
because it's such a boring and
repetitive writer he just keeps killing
off characters resurrecting him and
killing them off again because of the
Chrysalis orb uh sorry police officer on
a case but we will need you to both
generate actual lists of people that
might want to hurt you 24 hours to
figure this out but if we don't are you
willing to pay the ransom and do
anything to get my book back
[Music]
loved my writing you were wrong and
being wrong never felt so right oh that
sounded cool did I just make up a hit
song being wrong never felt so right
with The Adams Family staying up all
night yep I was right it's a hit I gotta
go call Sharon all righty well
congratulations sarge don't forget about
us when you become a famous author
Terry's writing sucks parlov is lying to
him what why I don't know
he's buttering him up
because Lawson and parlov stole their
own books
well they stole their own books it's
plain to see but who's on the case The
Adams Family
Terry is Gomez I'm cousin it you are
Wednesday let's do this okay weeks ago
why do you think these guys run it
together they hate each other they spend
an hour arguing over the name of the
dragon and The Hobbit small
small
[Music]
it's Smaug by the way point Lawson but
yes they're mortal enemies which is why
they think we'll never suspect them of
being in cahoots oh but they kahooted
Rosa they kahooted
to get people excited like when Carly
Rae Jepsen puts out an amazing single
and you have to wait six weeks for the
album to come out she's great I'm not
apologizing so Perlo have contacted
Terry because he knows sarge is a super
fan and can be manipulated yes he's been
giving Terry presents since last year
and Terry's novel gave parlov another
chance to manipulate him unless he's a
possible part Love Actually like
Sergeant's writing read the first
sentence
yep I loved it very much so
interesting
very very interesting guys Captain Holt
has no pants on
um
what he has no pants on is what here are
the facts at 11 55 a.m Captain Holton
walked past us holding a hot bowl of
soup at 1203 PM I heard him yell
ouch then at 1207 he called Gina into
his office she entered holding nothing
one minute later she left holding an
opaque bag
Captain Holt's pants were in that bag
his knees are in the breeze he's in his
undies that evidence is circumstantial
oh so you guys want visual confirmation
not really
hey Captain I just need you to sign
something at my desk real quick just
leave it on the couch dismissed okay sir
you're gonna freak Yo-Yo Ma is in the
precinct and he's giving out autographs
Yo-Yo Ma is on tour in Australia right
now how would you know that
I'm
gonna die
I got you Jake no no I called it it's
nice hey hey and there's another bowl of
soup since you spilled yours earlier but
you're gonna have to come over here to
get it all right I'm sick are you
wasting time so yes I spilled some
minestrone on my pants and I'm sitting
in my underwear happy yes
ah
sir I need you to sign off on look at us
just three people with pants on having a
normal conversation yep no story here
foreign